tonight on Kitchen Nightmares I'm here
help good an Italian restaurant on the
brink of disaster we've busted our ass
all day and lost money we should have
[__] stayed in bed run by a family
that is being torn apart if this place
fails I don't even know if we'll be
together
anymore there's a stubborn father who is
impossible to please this thing is awful
s I feel that sometimes you hate me a
son who was unable to step up why can't
you show me the same fire I had and just
go up there and dve
and a mother who is caught in the middle
you got to get out of here [__] God damn
it you don't have to be back there I'm
tired of playing referee I don't want to
be everyone's mom they've got everything
on the line we're losing our houses
we're losing our life we're losing our
everything and Gordon Ramsay is their
last hope I thought I had a job to do
but now it's just become 10 times
[__] bigger get ready for an intense
I've been wanting you to notice me since
I was 13 emotional diabetes is the worst
disease you can have I just want my
family to be healthy and happy very
special I never stopped loving you
Kitchen
Nightmares 30 m north of Detroit lies
the township of mome county home to jees
its owner Joe and his wife Kathy have
owned several successful Italian
restaurants in the span of 25 years
after retiring they decided to open jeis
with the dream of passing it down to
their son Sam I opened it with the
expectations that we would put Sam on
his feet and Joe and I could just go to
Florida or wherever but it just hasn't
worked out that way Sam basically said
dad I going to step up to the plate I
want to work day and night you and Mom
can come a little better at a time but
when they started working 20 hours a
week to me it was like another empty
promise you want to go get your son CU
every time we I try to explain he's got
to walk away Sam did you walk off the
line no it's a nightmare for two reasons
the lack of
customers and the hell that goes on in
the kitchen you're serving Frozen
[__] salmon I mean no matter what you
do you can boil it in grease it's still
going to be F I prove you wrong you
prove me wrong then I'm not supposed to
have no input I'm not supposed to be
able to change anything usually people
roast them on the Barbe no that's the
way you do it I'm just supposed to
basically be a shadow and somebody that
he can just say it's your fault okay D
whatever you say I'm Brian I'm a truck
driver but I Chef here part time right
here Joe I've known Joe for forever he's
getting up there a little bit in years
and he's just he's getting tired and I
don't think that his son is stepping up
to the plate you don't have to be back
there I'm not they just start pushing me
too many hours they're not pushing you
you're pushing you I'm a diabetic some
days I don't feel like coming in some
days I can't even roll out of bed but I
have to be here that's my
responsibility sugar is low I'm [__]
up here I got I got it my dad's health
is not good by any standards it's the
most heartbreaking thing to see I just
want my family to be healthy and happy
everything else doesn't matter if
anybody can help our family it would
probably be Chef
[Music]
Ramy
I'm here to work with a family in a
restaurant that's in crisis the
kitchen's run by father and son and
they're constantly at each other's
throat the mother's torn between them
both she's actually here to pick me
up W he just got to smile that's got
that's a good sign I was excited and
nervous but I know once he was here
everything was going to be fine nice to
see you my Daddy and thank you so much
for come to pick me
up now the rest is run by Joe your
husband my husband Joe jppy and Joe's
the head chef and Sam's the Sue Chef
exactly is Sam taking over from Joe or
well that was the plan but it's not
happening and I'm sure Sam's a little
disappointed he's 28 he must be ready
for it now surely he's about the
maturity of about a 23 year old right
he's not
ready and the rest's only been open for
2 years yeah and I'm in that big time I
got my house in forclosure I owe about
$150,000 outside of that outside the
house how am I losing the house I can
sleep anywhere but the business that's
everything I have and at my age I can't
start over again how does um Joe feel
about this he's miserable inside damn if
this place fails I don't even know if
we'll be together anymore this is it
this is it this is my little place hope
you brought your magic
one excellent thank you you're welcome I
think Chef Ramsey may be overwhelmed
this time it's not just as simple as a
menu change or firing somebody I think
it's a little more complex and I think
this is where you'll be okay
great that palomino sauce Sam I know you
don't want to listen to me yeah I do
exactly how you say you put way too much
white wine on it and that's why you get
in the burning he told me to put the
white wine with Joe overseeing the
kitchen Sam will be cooking a menu
designed by his father for Chef Ramsey I
think Chef Ramsey is going to come in
here order a few things and he's going
to say they're
horrible Welcome To theis tutorial
please allow my family and I to
introduce you to the essence of Italy
they World family recipes and cozy
[Music]
atmosphere this place has only been open
for 2 years it looks like something from
the
1970s hello Hi how are you I'm joh nice
to meet you nice to see you and you're
one of the servers obviously I am one of
the servers excellent what would you
recommend my dy I would recommend the
eggplant roll and Tini that's our house
specialty okay great and um I'll start
off with the potato skins and the
octopus salad okay and I'll keep hold of
the menu cuz I'm I'm going to read on
okay thank you so much you're
welcome Essence obviously my ass what do
we get we need octopus salad potato
skins okay that's first and I'll guide
you through when I saw Chef Ramy ordered
I put salad every part of me wanted to
say we're out of it can you please take
the salad out of the window please but
how would that look wow have to put
salad that was quick be thank you my
darling enjoy thank you
[Music]
Jesus got the octopus like
rubber excuse me Jesus Christ it's like
a mouth full of Hubba Bubba it should be
down in a frying pan very slow I got it
I got it dad let me get this PO skin is
that normally that cherry that oist I
think it is I've heard people say that
before would you be my guest just I'll
be your guest please my
D very tough mhm but I tasted it I'm
like oh my gosh we serve this [__] I
mean basically that's what it was that's
what it tasted like horrible octopus is
chewy horrible and how are the potato
skins the cheese is um hideous that good
yeah would you like to try one no I
don't enough how we doing guys Octopus
as [__] say it's chewy these are hideous
too Che is disgusting oh boy I always
brag about how good my food is and how
good my restaurant is and if then I step
up to the plate I am going to cook every
individual dinner in this restaurant put
it
[Music]
my hey Clint rolling Tey thanks you're
welcome thank
[Music]
you I I think it's so much one I mean
that's my person thing is too much wine
I you know I make a new one can't really
identify any flavors because it's just
absolutely piping out almost like it's
been nuked in the microwave for 3
minutes I can cook every dish that he
had and I guarantee you he's going to
love every one of them what H going on
in there and why aren't you back here
well because maybe they should try you
out see you know what's going on
honestly sounds like there's a war going
on it's incredible there many [__]
complaints in two [__] ears relax
relax my ass God damn
it two [__]
ears coming up family is one thing we're
in the business family tensions boil
over I want to be the best chef but I
want you to be my father too Joe deals
with his deteriorating Health can't do
it anymore man look this [__] sugar is
slow I'm [__] up diabetes is the worst
disease you can have you know been
without insurance since we open this
restaurant can Gordon bring this family
together is a good Chef he he he likes
to cook or is this restaurant don't over
cook it's done Tam it looks like [__]
and family why can't you show me the set
of balls Beyond repair I've been [__]
doing that [__] since I was 13 nice to
you you don't see me see
what you don't see
[Music]
me after sensing Gordon's disappointment
with lunch the family regroups in the
kitchen we got to stop being the mother
the husband the son family is one thing
we are in the business yeah you're and
if you think that it's that
responsibility be the chef you be to be
the goddamn best [__] Chef on this
side of Mississippi I want to be the
best chef on this side it's we're in
Michigan but I want you to be my father
too you know I just want to grab my dad
and give him a hug and say look it's
going to be all right you just got to
trust in me a little bit now it's time
for Joe Sam and Sue Chef Bryan to hear
the cold old hard truth from Chef Ramsey
hello sir how are you nice to meet you
you said on the back of the menu step
into jeppe and I'm going to take you
through a romantic authentic restaurant
in Italy I like the passion but the
Pet's [__] that eggplant Bland milky
spongy and then piping hot in the middle
like it had been blasted in the
microwave and just it was yeah so you
don't bake them fresh
no Chef we got probably 3,000 respond
that we did this question here and we
did get one negative thing about the
food so where the [__] are they then I
don't know you don't need questionnaires
they don't ring you up say by the way
I'm not coming back they just don't come
back they vote with their feet why are
we serving potato skins do I want to
come to an authentic Italian restaurant
with potato skins absolutely not a lot
of people come here with their kids and
their kids don't want uh Hey I've lived
in Italy I've seen Italian families the
way they eat together they don't serve
[__] children in Italy potato skins
with plastic cheese I'm can to show you
there's no [__] reason to have potato
skins on an Italian menu Joe I'm not
asking for excuses I'm here to help yeah
but everything I'm saying all you're
doing is find me [__] excuses don't
[__] me and I won't [__] you do
you understand yes I got told in the car
are the pressure is facing this place
but I can see why we're in the [__] the
food's crap guys I thought I had a job
to do but now it's just become 10 times
[__] bigger I'll see you later on
this afternoon get some thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
sir jeie may have been born in Italy but
he's certainly not delivering Italian
authentic Cuisine here in Michigan he
may say it on the back of the menu but
he's not delivering in flavor that's for
[Music]
sure before Gordon can formulate his
plan to turn around the restaurant he
wants to see a dinner service and the
staff in action how are you today go
ahead how are you Hi how are you my name
is
[Music]
Carol does that come off
that looks like a [__] to
[Music]
Hi how are
you three yeah not a
problem Hi how are you hav been okay
here so far good you ready honey I am I
would like to add meat meat sace thank
you D thank
[Music]
you fire and hole baby and here we go
what's that there BR it's going to be uh
order Rose potato How can there be rosed
potatoes in the microwave that's the
program here so just Happ he wants has
he lost his [__] marbles my dad feels
like he just needs to push the food out
real fast you know he wants his melt
cheese in the microwave but you can't
take shortcuts like that it's horrible
you know food comes out quick is that
normal really quick quick I think and
what would you like I'll have the uh
Ravi onlyi Florentine thank you
sometimes salads their soups and then
their main entree comes all at
[Music]
once I would like the uh
you guys want to do the wings as
well enjoy okay I always call it fast
food Italian fast food Italian yeah yeah
you're not wrong there the sauce is warm
but the inside of it needs to be warmed
up okay honey hey Brian can you please
warm this for me y more crap don't want
it don't want to redo that was a ravioli
with alfredo the pillows are
why we have so much problem with that I
I don't get it Brian yes the inside's a
little bit on the cool side okay I put
in the
[Music]
microwave unbelievable two things I can
definitely confirm the first thing is
they're fast unfortunately too fast for
their own good the second thing is when
they're fast they're sloppy over 12
dishes have come back and this place is
about to explode
unbelievable is everything okay tonight
um I don't know if I like this too much
do you want something else it's a little
bit too lemony I'll be right back excuse
me I'm going to have a reorder here a
little too lemony may we should s the
one goddamn recipe of maybe we should
put your ingredients on little bit olive
oil what just straight olive oil or you
want like a caramal
mix did you put your salt pepper and
garlic in here did coming through I got
it I was trying to ask you what you
wanted and if I say calamari mix you
should know what I mean I didn't hear
Kar mix that's what I said to see my
father not trust me was just getting
down right frustrating I don't know what
else to show my
father this is supposed to be black and
it wasn't black and and that's all fat
you need a new steak what they say I
need a old did you want another steak
yes okay medium rare blacken Sam you
know what blacking means yeah I put it
on a flat top I put a caj seasoning on I
put it on there and I cook both Sid
medium Weare blacken is that what
blackened is I do need another stake
medium rare blackened okay very
blackened very spicy I whatever where's
the kchen spice I got it over here Sam
is like a new puppy that you have to
constantly pay attention to him this is
a joke he's not ready to run their
business why don't we ever add towels in
this line there's a towel right there I
won't even wipe my ass with that there's
tows right there there tow down here Joe
did not like what the hell how' that
steak on that redo you want me to cook
it it doesn't come out of my ass okay
all right I hope it doesn't come out of
your ass don't touch his steak
what the hell Sam get your ass out of
there let's try to make him
[Music]
happy Joe did not like after multiple
dishes are returned Joe kicks Sam out of
the kitchen okay Sam get your ass out of
there and takes matters into his own
hands you want to make somebody happy
and then somebody happens to be your
father you want to make him proud of you
you want to make him believe in you but
I don't know how to do that after 28
years I'm still
trying now I'm really seriously starting
to understand what it's like behind the
scenes in the kitchen you got Brian
there and Sam cooking fine but too fast
for their own good all of a sudden Joe
walks in marks his orders and then
disappears but when he walks in they all
stand to attention and he talks them
like dirt unfortunately that dirts his
son
[Music]
sad right that was tough we've got
ourselves in a real horrible rut cooking
in that kitchen because it's just
slamming food I've never seen so much
food go in a microwave in all my life
it's like no one's striving to be
better you tell me how you feel about
the Frozen food I hate
[Music]
it I'm embarrassed to say it's my
food why don't you tell Dad that you
want to cook fresh dad I want to cook
fresh I want to cook
[Music]
fresh is Sam a good
chef he's he he likes to
cook I don't want my children insulted
whether it's true or not it cussed
me and only a mother would understand
that and what's his weaknesses you're
not committed you put 25 hours a week I
used to work that my when I have my
first restaurant one day why haven't you
been committed my father doesn't really
talk to me that much and you know I I
feel that sometimes you hate me I don't
want to be to you you because you don't
put enough time in here to get involved
where's your fire in your belly I mean
what can you show me the same set of
balls that I had and just go up there
and try to make something out of it I've
been [__] doing that [__] since I was
[__] 13 next to you you don't see me
you don't see me see what Sam gra
scrubbing floors next you I've been
wanting you to [__] notice me for a h
long I don't how many times you looked
at me and said hey holy [__] [__]
good job not once they don't tell me
about that Bullit you're you know you're
long enough to do that Sam I'm not long
enough for you to say good [__] job
one time come on I I don't know what
else to
say no matter what there's always a
complaint I have not served him anything
without him saying it's not done right
it hurts I mean still to this day I'm
almost 30 years old and that stupid [__]
hurts we've got our cards out on the
table now I want to see the passion I
want to see that little bit of flame
relit the lights back on
[Music]
okay in the morning Gordon wants to
focus his attention on Joe before the
customers coming let's have 2 minutes
together not his battles with his son
but his battle with a crippling disease
how does it affect you at level of
diabetes diabetes is the worst disease
you can have I got pain in my legs every
day and you have a uh proper medical
insurance no I don't oh come on I don't
okay we can afford I had to cut it off
you know I've been without insurance for
you know since we open this
restaurant God's sake you know rest is
the first thing you need you can't be
here 7 days a week I built this
restaurant I've been putting in 70 hours
a week I would like my son to run this
restaurant that me kick back but Sam
doesn't follow through and now I'm stuck
with this thing on my shoulder and I'm
keep on digging until I dig myself out
you can't be a [__] master I know hey
you've got to look after
yourself you know you keep me posted on
how you feeling okay thank you thank
you before Gordon can turn around jeis I
want to turn up a notch he needs to test
Sam's abilities I want to cook off and
reignite Joe's passion both of you cook
something unique anything you want the
front of house staff are going to taste
they won't know who's cooked what but
what they will know is which dish is the
best because that dish tonight is going
on as a special ready let's go when Chef
Ramsey said that we were going to have
the cook off I kind of just wanted to do
something simple but bold and hopefully
impressed Chef Ramsey and impressed my
father on top of it everything hand
bought freshly made pasta fresh lasagna
fresh salmon asparagus double pork chops
garlic Basel blow me away okay
I saw the salmon just caught out of the
water maybe two hours ago I had to go
for the salmon I love
it I used take s por chop and I sear
some scallops with some pachera with
some Italian sauage and Calon cheese
okay let's
go okay right two dishes first one's a
broed salmon with asparagus coated in
egg finished with Pro on cheese and the
salmon has been CH broiled next to that
we got a pork chop stuffed serve on the
side with grilled potatoes and gratinate
it with proon cheese take a taste and
then pass it down
yeah I was confident in my dish because
I always cook with a little flare and a
little flavor to
it okay we're going to start with uh mom
out of both dishes which one would you
choose as a special I would take the
pork chop put it with the potatoes not
the pasta with the asparagus mhm so
better both that's the fair answer
Diplomat okay Brian out of both dishes
which one would you choose the uh pork
chop pork chop yes right darling which
one would you choose definitely the pork
chop and the mushrooms okay the pork
chop Tony out of both dishes which one
would you choose
um I would have to say there salmon M
salmon okay Dawn if I was just looking
at the menu and hadn't tasted them I'd
probably go with the
salmon but after tasting it I'd go with
a pork
chop right well done oh thank you yeah
really well
done sure I was a little disappointed
I'm not going to lie but at the same
time I want him to be better than me
because I need someone to look up to I
need a mentor in my life my choice out
of both those
dishes they're both good enough to go on
this menu tonight yes that's what's
going to happen two specials
congratulations good dish I wish he
would have want to tell you the truth
you know which his dish looked really
good tonight you're going to be cooking
your father's special make sure you know
the dish inside out you got it I'm real
fired up not only because we're putting
a new item out there that everybody's
going to taste but me and my father are
going to work together on each other's
dishes and I know they're going to be
excellent
with everyone feeling good about
tonight's specials Gordon begins to work
on another problem of this restaurants
the lack of communication between Joe
Sam and Kathy I'm here to help but it's
it's every hour it's changing because
I've never ever quite come across such a
difficult restaurant situation in all my
life because the restaurant is one thing
but the biggest problem is the family
and what I want you to do is I want you
to write a letter and say in that letter
what you really want to say to them both
write that letter for me will please
will and don't show any of them it I
won't my objective tonight is to push
the specials you've got one made by the
father and one from the upand cominging
son want to make sure that you sell
them with Joe momentarily out of the
kitchen Gordon sees a chance to speak
with Sam we just give me two minutes to
Drew
yeah tonight when you get out of here
you get home I want you to tell me in a
letter to your father yeah what you
really feel about him what kind of
figure that guy is in your life yeah I
want you to put it on paper for me
discreetly and I mean
discreetly Hi how are you good thank you
first customers here yeah here we go
yeah Booth over here okay we're going to
put the pork okay and the scallop on TI
um I am going to try
the specialy special as well thank you
okay here we go you're going to be
expediting in and out and you're on the
line yeah yeah good good man so it's
going to be two pork jeppi okay two pork
jeppis all right let's show them what
we're made
oil very nice what a breath of fresh air
every dish like that yes yes sir salmon
enjoy your meal 27 two PS you got it I
really like the pork chop don't overcook
it Sam it's just boom boom done once
again Joe can't give up control of the
kitchen it's one di instead of
Expediting and making sure orders are
filled quickly he's at the stove cooking
Sam's dishes it took 25 minutes for a
color maret Jo are you Expediting no not
really I can't read without my glasses
your glass is around your
neck [__] it this is his heart this is
his place but he's got to learn that he
can't always be in the middle of the
action I can't do it anymore man what on
brother sh he's going to kill himself my
sugar is low I'm [__] up Joe expedite
and let sand C Jesus Christ want to
switch I I'll dress them up I can see me
I got [__] things back in on I got
Che you wanted J to expedite but that's
Italian in him never let go never give
up never surrender help me pull him off
because that's the only way I mean
literally we got to pull him on how'd
you get him off that stove he's
magnetized there is that a steak SW done
I don't like this thing I don't like it
it's SW down Sam it looks like [__] Sam
yeah kick him off there I'm sorry dude
but you're [__] Sugar's up you got to
get up thank
[Music]
you with Joe finally off the line if
that kid we don't let him stand and fail
a few times he's never going to stand up
Sam and Brian regained control of the
kitchen look at that my friend there you
go Tomy and finish the service very good
and while the staff was cleaning up
seconds Gordon cornered
Joe is it your wish that one day Sam
takes over yeah I want you to go home
and just write a short letter how you
feel about him what he means to you and
what you want him to be one day I want
you to talk from the heart and you got
to keep it between you and I I will I
[Music]
will even though the specials were a big
success this restaurant still has a long
way to go before it's ready for relaunch
tonight wasn't good enough for this
restaurant if we're going to establish
any form of longevity I know we can all
do better tomorrow we are going to do
better we're going to relaunch and
Market this place so you get yourself
off to bed yeah so you're going to work
for a change I mean you're going
to you're such a rockweiler I swear to
God okay good night immediately after
the family and staff left Chef Ramsay's
team went into high gear working through
the night to transform jeis into a
contemporary Italian
eery
what a beautiful morning for a relaunch
how are we good when I first arrived the
restaurant was dated and it's almost
like you'd opened a dated restaurant
this is what you call a modern
contemporary Italian are you ready to
see the new deers yes good let's go
let's go let's
go come through woohoo look at this
ho oh my is it
[Music]
beautiful it was claustrophobic now it's
a modern contemporary Italian restaurant
I just couldn't believe that something
like this could be done and it just the
time that I slept I'm totally tooken
back by this it's like a different place
new bars New
drapes nice new
chairs oh my God oh my God he's holding
Sammy he was just born when I saw my
father look at the pictures of me and
him when I was a little boy you know
when I saw a tiar come to those eyes I
almost lost it you feel like you're
stepping inside something historic now
it's modern yes I love it run by a an
amazing family joke I just I don't know
how you do stuff like that you deserve
it my man come here
you and you just doing it huh is it
lovely it's beautiful isn't it beautiful
it's beautiful I'm so happy because now
we have a real chance it's a new
beginning this is
beautiful something even more important
now
Marketing in order to relaunch this
restaurant we're going to host the first
ever jeppe's bathon with the American
Diabetes Association yes I'm
overwhelmed you know bathon for diabas
which uh lost my brother and and my
m so it's it's it's a big thing bullet
for diabetes it took your brother it
took your mother not taking my father
it's not taking
[Music]
you hi guys hello nice to
see thank you so much for coming and
thank you so much for being part of our
first ever jep's
Bon we greeted by a warm crowd cheering
for us like we were some celebrities you
guys hungry there you go it was great to
see my father passing out super and
talking to the customers and getting
them all excited about our restaurant
thank you so much appreciate
it I have no words for this but I'm glad
that you guys are here and uh out spread
the word about diabetes we're going to
fight it and with help for you people
we're going to do
[Applause]
it after the success of the first ever
jepi bathon Chef Ramsey and the staff
returned to the restaurant to prepare
for for the relaunch the condensed menu
it's fresher it's quicker it's smaller
and more importantly it's 10 times more
exciting the classic soups passive VII
Minon soup that's the heartbeat of the
restaurant okay the chicken pan look at
that it's a new way modern and something
complete when Chef Ramsey presented our
new menu and I saw that all the old
[__] was off I was excited we're at
2008 now and here's the man you to prove
it more importantly if this restaurant's
got chance of survival we got to
communicate and stick together tonight
right now I'm so excited I feel like I'm
18 years old again 1
2 coming up yeah it's not going to be
you on the line can Gordon finally bring
this Father and Son together yeah I only
want you to be proud of me or will the
staff tear them apart come on guys
concentrate this thing is awful Sam and
make dinner service a huge
disappointment I want to leave you know
who I blame I blame all this on you what
a [__] idiot you don't want to miss
what's coming up on Kitchen
Nightmares for tonight's dinner service
Chef Ramsey has assigned Sam to run the
line and Joe to expedite we've been
given every opportunity now it's time
for me to step up to the plate and knock
it out of the park hello welcome to the
new jepp TR
three are you ready to
order plan are
wonderful I'm ready to rock and
roll this is a very very important night
it's not just about the relaunch of De
seis it's a transition that's what's got
to take place tonight will Sam step up
to the mark and can Joe let go and give
Sam the confidence to run this place
time will
tell all right I got three marcelas
coming right now I need them baby only
30 minutes into service medum wall is
coming right after and stubborn Joe is
on the line cooking again Dad do you
want to get off the line we got it I got
three marcelas coming on a fly I need
them Sammy Kad get off the line oh
Marcel coming
hard yeah it's not going to be you on
the line you understand my father wasn't
letting go he doesn't need to be back
there right in the action if anything
he's making things more complicating
priority chicken Marcella what's wrong
it's wrong oh [__] Sam yes not now buddy
I've got pink chicken okay come on sorry
about that come on come on slow it down
I'd rather to wait in extra 5 minutes
and send our [__] pink chicken yes
sure take your
time kind having a problem with the
lasagna hey hey you guys fam they need
this cooked more all right they said
it's cold yes ma'am don't rush it we're
not rushing yeah we are we're going
right back this Grill sucks dad do you
want to get off the line this thing is
awful Sam yeah that Char Brer I've made
the best things in the world off of it I
was again seeing the same thing my dad
getting worn out getting angry dad go we
got it if we can't handle it then we
shouldn't be here and it was really
starting to get to me
Joe Joe 2 seconds yeah they have to
learn to do it without you yeah take 10
minutes out get some fresh air please
hey they're fine get out please they
have to learn all right I got this [__]
cracking I just got to get a few my
working okay please do it man come on
send it man let's go go go go go
go
get
out [__]
hell if I was
rich sure the hell wouldn't be here well
I'd still be
here there
yeah Ste we got D around this bread sit
down I've got the bread [__] H guys
unbelievable unbelievable this guy is
incredible he had to leave the line he's
down and out and he's beat so they've
got to step up to the mark and it's now
or never for those guys they got to do
it for Joe the restaurant and more
importantly for themselves come
on there you are thank you you're
welcome that table was here half an hour
after us enjoy and we still haven't
received our food yet honey it's coming
how we doing this Samy coming man can
can I plate this plate it plate it I'm
plating it I'm not playing I'm plating
it okay great you want a goddamn award I
heard all the noise in the kitchen I
mean it's a zoo back there if they're
screwing around it's to run a smooth
ship I do apologize for the delay okay
we got a seafood po there you go dear
please enjoy your food hey yeah quality
up here where's the quality right here
quality's there thank you unfortunately
Brian's goofing off is causing Sam to
lose his Focus you want quality I got
you quality
huh and the customers are feeling the
effects it's I
apologize can you please reorder this
for me what's the matter with this the
inside's on the cool side come
on okay ran Sam come here a minute from
behind the line sounds like we're
[__] around th's coming back raw all
I want to do is cut the [__] around
and just concentrate a little bit cuz if
you concentrate [__] won't come back raw
we waited an hour for our food now I'm
sitting here 20 minutes waiting for raw
fish just quit the [__] around you'll
see a difference in the standard come on
guys I know we can do better [__] it
here we can do better come on let just
concentrate yes
Che screw that [__] [__] it's don't
cold and roll you know whose fault all
this is tonight it's his the people are
done eating and she hasn't got her
dinner I haven't even gotten my food J I
want to leave right you know who I blame
I blame all this on
you it's not difficult so stop making
[__] pathetic excuses here we got
Chef ramsy giv us a hand and now you got
to turn around and basically spit in his
face and say it's your fault that I suck
that's horrible I feel sorry for the man
honey it's coming we don't even want it
hold
you just got to slow down stop being a
[__] goofball throwing food out there
okay great nothing complicated
outstanding good man good man B6 is
ready to walk we got a table walking
let's go guys get back in your [__]
truck right coming to me looking for
excuses excuses I ain't got no excuses
you just said you blame me on the [__] I
at when I first arrived that's cool
thanks
Chef huh what a [__]
idiot supposed be in this together
right I would never commit here again
[__] cement mixer gu pain in the ass
where's
Brian in this hugely important dinner
service I got three marcelas coming on a
fly I need them Samy dishes started to
come back Sam I've got pink chicken pull
it together come on I want to leave and
when Chef ramsy tried to restore order
quit the [__] around you'll see a
difference in the standard Brian
couldn't handle the criticism you know
who I blame I blame all this on you you
get back in your [__] truck coming to
me looking for excuses thanks Che and
packed it in supposed to be in this
together right what a [__] idiot gu a
pain in the ass leaving a father and son
to rely on each other to save this
restaurant come on I'm not giving up I'm
not [__] giving up all right Sam real
marcelas is three marcelas coming right
now okay I'll take care of the S okay I
got a shrim scampy coming on the Fly uh
salmon right after you got it we got
this all right I couldn't have asked for
any better father son finishing off yes
yes sure I'm so happy to know that me
and my father can work side by side
without trying to kill each other I mean
it's a great feeling that's what I
always wanted excellent hey what a
difference they look great beautiful is
delicious yeah you have to try this it
is so delicious I like a lot yeah you
did an excellent job today
Sam I'm proud of us you know what I mean
I think over hul my son they really
really good he pulled through so that
shows me a lot he made me realize the
family it's everything and that's what
we have with each other this place is
good at work
pop after an incredibly successful
relaunch the only thing left for Gordon
to repair is the family we have come a
long way from the first minute I walked
in here I saw a family that wasn't even
talking to each other they're talking
over each other and nothing was sinking
in I asked all of you individually to
write a letter
and before I go I want you to read the
letter
Kathy to Joe and Sam I see that our
lives and the way we exist and treat
each other is not acceptable any
longer we need real change before it's
too
late Joe I don't want to be a
widow please try to trust and Sam you
need to teach and support him you need
to let him make mistakes you need to
pull
back Sam my beautiful
son it's time to [__] stand
up you know this has always been for you
and about you in your new
life don't be
scared it's time for you to shine and
start busting some ass love Ma and Kathy
well done my darling that was
tough Sam you'll know out the woods I
thought me we didn't have time yeah
well dear Dad this letter is coming
straight from the
heart I have always looked up to
you Dad I really truly only want you to
be proud of me it feels like I am a big
disappointment to you because of my past
immaturities I really am sorry if I
disappointed you and even more sorry if
I hurt
you I love you Dad all I want is to take
this restaurant over and let you relax
we is all we have and without each other
we are
nothing love your son
[Music]
Sam
amazing I'm now the man the reason why
we're all
here take your time
to
Sam Hi Sam I am writing this few words
to let you know that this last couple of
days it made me realize how important
you are to
me and I came to
realize that you are
ready I want to take
charge finally I am really proud to have
a son like
you PS
I never stop loving you and I'll be
there for you no matter what
happens love you
that you're an amazing
family youve just forgotten
it this is the closest I felt to my
husband and my son in a really long time
my father is saying that he loves me and
he's proud of me and he wants to me to
take over it's everything I always
wanted it's my dream come true Chef
Ramsey brought back the love that we had
that we almost lost and I'll never
forget that you are the American
[Music]
dream good night good
night tonight on Kitchen Nightmares what
a mess Chef Ramsey faces the most stubn
owner he's ever met Billy can you talk
to me please no have nothing to say his
Long Island restaurant is crumbling oh
my God what a disaster disaster but he
refuses to admit anything is wrong you
can't think this is good it's not bad
and everybody's
opinion his wife is a mess I don't know
what to do the chef doesn't care I don't
want to be a
chef and his staff is just plain angry
come on be a [__] baby Billy you're
not the man everyone here thought you
were you're a weak Man Billy when Gordon
gives him a dose of the truth this is
embarrassing so why can't you act like a
man and do something about it it's more
than this owner can handle I wouldn't
talk to my dog the way you talk to me go
[__] yourself I'll make it work myself
without his help with only one week to
turn it around everything's coming out
and this place is going to get clean
Gordon Ramsay's demands for change may
have this owner On The Run Billy I've
had it with these people and this
restaurant's doors may be closed almost
forever put the place up for [__]
sale I'm done
done Mount Si New York an upper middle
class town on the North Shore of Long
Island inhabited by the working class
and City commuters with no shortage of
trendy
eering and then there's the handlebar
hello handlebar how can I help you Bill
looy a former construction worker and
his wife Carolyn bought the handlebar
just one year ago oh boy the handle bar
was a really nice place and when I saw
it was for sale I jumped on it and our
specials menu when we came into the
handlebar we saw that it had been run
down but Billy being so
handsy now they're on we saw the
potential of having a great
place and it's Heyday this was the place
to be this was the place that the judges
came this was the place that the lawyers
came the doctors came now it's not like
that anymore the nightmare began when
70% of the money was coming from the bar
and almost nothing was coming from the
dining room when you can't turn 18
tables on a Friday or a Saturday night
you're in a lot of
trouble bill is an okay manager can I
bother you to make me a cup of coffee
Billy usually stays at the bar but being
an owner he has to be more
involved like answer the phone sobody on
the phone sometimes he can be very
grouchy now go put all the stuff back
where you got it then I didn't do like
his mood swings changed I've had it with
these
people this place is gross like dirt
filth that had been built up over the
past 20
years the interior it looks dated the
decor I think it's
great DEC menu I is basically the same
as I inherited with the restaurant they
look disgusting I don't know why anybody
orders them Melissa is an excellent Chef
I'm not a chef I don't claim to be a
chef I don't want to be a chef I not
very creative
5 minutes the food is crap my f
wasn't I think hiring me wasn't
necessarily the best idea I don't even
know what I'm doing here I don't intend
for it to be my career I really don't
think Melissa has any weaknesses as a
cook the day we call it quits is the day
we have not one penny to put into this
place we took out an equity line of
credit that's almost maxed out and
drained our savings account God help us
if the handlebar fails we risk losing
our house then I never want to lose my
house we need to worry about you and me
in The Handlebar bottom line if Chef
Ramsey doesn't come here our time is
very limited I definitely don't think
it's another
[Music]
year Chef Gordon Ramsey is on a mission
to turn the handlebar around go west
west left West right except he has one
small problem handle B I'm lost um I
what if you could help me okay I'm right
on the fork but do I go left do I go
right cuz they both say West okay so
you're going to Bear to the right right
and there's going to be like a big
shopping center right after it okay
there it is there
handlebar there's Gordon Ramsey how do
you know cuz cuz I just talked to him on
the phone get out of here really yeah
handle B finally now we're in Mount Si
just outside New York Mount Si sounds a
little bit like cide I hope it doesn't
taste like
it I'm a little nervous to meet chef
ramsy I'm Carolyn car how are you the
man is an expert at what he does the man
is a a well-renowned chef B
owns beautiful restaurants because I've
seen them on the Internet however you
like you don't get that way because
you're an idiot all right hello Gordon
ramse is like really hot he has like a
nice body and stuff like for an older
man he's very very hot I didn't want to
serve him cuz I just talk and I just
don't stop talking so I was nervous if I
said something stupid that I just
wouldn't stop and I would just keep
talking and talking and talking this is
our dinner menu right we also have our
price fix menu right and the early bird
specials okay great we'll have a quick
look thank you one menu two menu three
menu four menu right definitely quantity
let's hope it's quality I need to
continue to cook this because I [__]
up pizza fondue Filly minion fondue
swiss cheese fondue
weird ex you ready yet I'll go for the
sou of the day super of the day I'll go
for the seafood uh crepe as well and
then I'm going to finish with the fion
fondu fion please thank you D no problem
excellent that was nice and
busy dying room's empty look at the
place the decor's
ghastly it's so 80s even the fish tank's
been here longer than
me gosh what am I doing I think Chef
Ramsey came close to ordering the worst
things but you know everything that's
here is pretty much crap food thanks
yeah thank you no problem
New England clam
chowder is he say s is good when Chef
Ramsey was sitting there I was just
praying that he was going to be happy
with everything where's Bill let me see
if I can find him thank you oh dear
goodness Hy Gordon would like to see you
for an minute great first thoughts that
went through my head was oh my God than
and just like to say that's uh nicely
seasoned um very tasty and perfect for a
Winter's day I'm glad you enjoy it nice
Melissa does a nice
job grab I I'll check on the rest of
your food thank you very
much he said your soup was fabulous
really yes he loved it I think Melissa's
a great cook I think she's very creative
I think Melissa underestimates herself a
lot I thought it came out pretty shitty
this
time there's some beaves there's crab in
there there's Lobster and some shrimp in
there also thank you no
problem hi je Ramsey seems to have a uh
Habit to take his food apart before he
eats it so I'm looking forward to
hearing what he has to
say here we go how is everything rubbery
um the scallops are firm uh- the prawns
are way over cooked oh God and the crab
meat it's plastic it's imitation crab
meat yeah if you told me it's imitation
crab meat I wouldn't have B
it oh God help me well that was his
asset Seafood
crepe yeah that's Seafood crap this is
the worst of it I'm
sure
dear I'm waiting on my beef fondue
Philly minion fondue which is raw so why
am I waiting so
long there's the
steak and this is the
oil thank you no problem nothing like
waiting to cook your own meat is there
all right put that
in time for a little of
[Music]
prayer ah comes out looking like dog
food he Ted out I'm
leaving that was rancid pointless
tasteless a complete utter
joke cry why would you deep fry the
filimo one of the country's best steaks
deep fried are they stupid oh
[Music]
no I wanted him to be happy with us but
I kind of knew deep down inside that
there has to be something wrong with the
restaurant otherwise he wouldn't be here
oh my God what a disaster
disaster it's a disaster no it's
not after an underwhelming first meal
okay pull together Gordon realizes that
the owners and the chef are oblivious to
the restaurant's real problems what's
wrong with the business it's t room as
you see and we can't fill 18 tables on a
Friday night that's the
problem no the problem here is the
food the food's bad Bill I never really
had complaints about the food so that
was never really an area of concern to
me when the fondu arrived I mean that's
just a joke I don't enjoy the fondue
either but you're the chef aren you
you're the one that's you you're you're
running it as the head chef right that
that's the intent so change it I don't
know what to do about it have you lost
your passion I never had a passion to
begin
with I I don't want to be a
chef I was really shocked shocked that
that's the way she felt so you're not a
chef no I had applications for the job
here as a chef when she approached me
and said would you give me the
opportunity I mean you don't ask for
that opportunity if you don't care what
you're doing why did you take the job
Melissa if you're not a chef yeah the
guy was going out that was here okay um
I didn't think our situation was as bad
as I'm finding out minute by
minute coming up oh my God Almighty
Gordon's shocking kitchen investigation
this place hasn't been cleaned in years
that's disgusting leads to a wild
showdown between Billy and Gordon I
wouldn't talk to my dog the way you talk
to me go [__] yourself with the future
of The Handlebar on the line I don't
know what to do it's a mess will Billy
be able to put his pride aside and
accept Gordon's help I'm done I'm done
so done the hell with everything or will
he give up on the restaurant for good I
don't care if it's all for nothing Billy
you're not going to believe what happens
tonight on Kitchen
Nightmares having exposed Melissa's
apathy in the kitchen I don't need this
out of my Gordon observes a dinner
service to find out how her attitude is
affecting the
[Music]
food I know he's here to help but it's
still very nerve-wracking having someone
of his stature standing there staring at
you what are they there the mushrooms
is that how that goes out like that yes
holy
crap stuff
mushrooms gosh those mushrooms look sad
than the
customer Gordon said they're very sad
mushrooms why when just now actually
that's a recipe of my own I made it
myself I was very disappointed that it
wasn't presented to him the right way
people eat that [__] for you what's my
choice potato rice vegetable big potato
mashed potato french fries rice veggy we
used half instant half with fresh
potatoes why do they mix the powdered
mashed potatoes with fresh mashed
potatoes that's a way of reusing the
baked potatoes so you don't even
actually make fresh mashed potatoes no
no do you want mashed potato baked
potato french fries rice or vegetables
french
fries don't burn them please okay that's
burnt a little more done than usual but
other than that yeah
just an hour into dinner service and the
restaurant has run out of basic
vegetables we ran out of broccoli
cauliflower yeah and replaced them with
an unusual substitute radishes radishes
wow never heard of that before how old
you radishes honestly Gordon of course
not something I would you know expect
with my state you want some veg right
yeah you know is do anything to keep him
happy have we checked with Melissa I I
wouldn't eat the radishes either so
customers are complaining about no
vegetables any broccoli vegetable
carrots or cabbage
birge birge oh
stop they STS uh yeah that's a frozen
bag that's why it's
crap even though Melissa is managing to
keep up with the
orders the customers are still not
satisfied no I don't like it at all this
is UN it's not real PR and Gordon needs
Billy to finally understand that the
food is Leb Bar's biggest problem Billy
customers are complaining about the
food you can't walk around oblivious the
fact that you think this is good yeah
but it's not bad in everybody's
opinion you can't take care of
everybody's taste buds something that
some people like other people aren't
going to like that at all no one's got
any control and Basics here that have
just gone completely [__] wrong if
you accept it everybody else has
accepted it and truthfully you've
accepted it no absolutely not I was kind
of really disappointed I knew we needed
help I didn't think we were that bad I
was quite skeptical about his intentions
whatever really starting to dislike
[Music]
him after witnessing last night's
pathetic dinner service Gordon comes in
early for a kitchen inspection what a
mess nothing
labeled portions taken out that's
Dreadful broccoli last night we ran out
of vegetables God the chef can't be
bothered to cook fresh broccoli the
reminiscence of Exxon
Valdes oh my god when was the last time
the back of the fridge was clean and you
look at it what is that in there oh my
God
Almighty that there was a clam
oh what a mess the state of the fridge
Melissa you got 2 minutes has only
confirmed Gordon's belief that the
restaurant lacks true passion and
Leadership so you're in charge of the
kitchen and the general hygiene supposed
to be
yes why is it in a
mess uh it's 100 times cleaner than it
was 6 months ago sure it was okay when
was the last time you had a little wipe
down there or uh in here just just even
I've never done my God
unbelievable oh this is
embarrassing that usually does clean out
right okay I'm glad you're starting to
make excuses for it y if you thought
this was bad have a look at this Chef
Ramsey seemed to feel that I was making
excuses for everything and really had no
idea of the past practices that had gone
on here okay last night we served frozen
vegetables to customer and we got two
boxes of broccoli there you know I can't
do it all that's it you were happy to
serve frozen broccoli over fresh
broccoli I'm trying to open up your eyes
Billy and explain to you you know what
the current situation is when was the
last time this fridge was cleaned a week
ago oh come on this hasn't been cleaned
in years no it has no no no it hasn't
I'm sorry 21 years in the business I'll
bet every [__] dollar I have this
[__] place hasn't been cleaned in
years I'm disgusted put your hand down
there you still never did bend down and
touch it it was a big thing of denial
for him I'll take responsibility for the
fact that I haven't changed it but it's
not all my fault you know everything's
coming out and this place is going to
get cleaned I wish he'd give me a little
more credit for cleaning it up as much
as I have so far it looks 60 70% times
better than it used to look in here
really that's disgusting fine no it's
it's it's not fine we got a big problem
when was the last time that fridge was
steamed clean cleaned I had the kid in
there doing it last week did you check
what he' done no obviously not so why
can't you act like a man and do
something about it y my God I just don't
even know what to say
anymore he just keeps tearing apart
everything that wasn't done and not
giving me credit or uh pat on the back
for things that were
done unfuckingbelievable so that just
proves and confirms how weak this guy is
he's not running this place this place
is running him and is in need of a
[__] serious clean that is
appalling prompted by Gordon's shocking
Discovery Melissa enlists the weight
staff to do a thorough cleaning what do
you Ed to clean that F and soap it's
disgusting I really wish I had a mask on
me right now
Billy just two seconds
here I was hoping he was going to tell
me I understand Billy that this isn't
your fault but it really needs to be
taken care of so let's take care of
it I'm [__] pissed off and I'm upset
on the kind of [__] that I've just
discovered in there time to drag me
through the mud some more it is what it
is you don't seem one [__] ounce
bothered about it Billy you can't just
stick your head back in the sand ignore
it Billy sure you can what do you want
me to do flip out and yell and scream
like you do that's not my way the
responsibility is yours Billy I guess
you want something done right I guess
you have to do it yourself maybe I just
get rid of everybody in the restaurant
I'll do it all myself and then when it
doesn't work out and then when I drop
dead because I [__] sleep 2 hours a
day then maybe it'll get done or maybe
who cares once you're dead it doesn't
make difference anyway oh come on now I
feel you're copping out of me now no
because now I'm just getting dragged
through the mud you're a weak Man Billy
I really justad had enough I was not
going to be ridiculed
just for the sake of needing his help
finished can you at least talk to me
no Billy can you talk to me please no I
have nothing to say Billy I wouldn't
talk to my dog the way you talk to me go
[__] yourself that's right the hell with
everything I'll make it work myself
without his help everything in my life
that I've ever set out to do I did on my
own
finish I'm done
what a weak
Man
Billy unable to accept Gordon's
criticism Billy Billy decides he's had
enough [__] him [__] him [__] them the
fridge is disgusting I've asked it to be
cleaned he's telling me I'm dragging him
through the mud and he [__] walks out
he's mad right now and he's being
stubborn he doesn't want you to leave he
wants your help he's just not right now
he's to a shame to admit it I just want
him to act responsible while Gordon
tries to make sense of Billy's actions
he doesn't have to act like a baby Billy
rehearses a speech to Gordon I am so
done I make me own I have nothing to say
to you not a word there was nothing in
my head that made me want to think and
reconsider about doing this can you go
out there and just you know have a word
with them you guys are the backbone of
this place can't just the tow in I knew
Billy would get mad done just [__]
done with all this [__] but honestly
you don't face the truth you can't do
anything about it we've been busting our
ass trying to help you out you're giving
up on yourself this place and all us and
us I wouldn't talk to my dog the way
that jackass talks to me I'm done he's
telling you the truth though Billy great
there's ways to go about it 46 years old
never been talked to like that by
anybody and you know what the only thing
that's keeping me from [__]
hitting him with a [__] baseball bat
is that I'd go to [__] jail for it
I'm done done done finished and you're
not the man everyone here thought you
were Billy absolutely not you're going
to give up and you're going to give up
on all of us fine be a [__] baby
Billy [__] it I'm
done yeah you know what put the place up
for [__] sale and go back to
construction and enjoy my [__] life
the way I used to before all of this
[__]
we'll go to bankruptcy court and just
give it all up [__] it I'm done bye so
help me God I will not open the door
tomorrow you can all go [__] yourselves
and I don't care if it's all for nothing
do not care Billy you know what I'll
survive somehow Billy [__]
you
unbelievable having just missed her
chance to diffuse the situation Carolyn
now faces the prospect of running The
Handlebar
alone very upset I have a husband that's
ready to throw in the towel so here I am
stuck holding the
bag let me help you I want you to help
me but I don't know what to do I have a
job that I have to work so I can pay my
mortgage sure okay I don't know what to
do why can't we work at turning this
around I would love to work a turn this
around okay let me open the restaurant
tonight okay okay I'm feeling that I'm
going to do what I have to do to make
everything work because I'm not walking
out now and I'm not flushing the last 17
years of my life down the bowl to
further Inspire Carolyn to move forward
with the plan Gordon shows her the
dedication of her staff what a
difference it's looking great it looks
so much better you've done a great job
we were cleaned the walk in we were more
or less just doing it to just show that
like we are dedicated and we do want
this to work Billy's gone whether he
comes back lateer or not it's not going
to affect what we're doing tonight we're
opening and we're opening with a clean
fridge healthy attitude we're hungry to
get this place full yes let's go her
courage now bolstered by her staff's
support Carolyn leaves Billy a message
Billy I'm not going to stop now I will
do whatever it takes to make my
restaurant succeed with Chef Ramsey's
help I'll succeed I just told him my
determination that I'm going forward
with this regardless of if he wanted to
or
not the restaurant is about to open for
dinner but to get the handlebar moving
in the right direction Gordon makes some
quick additions to the menu Melissa
let's do a special tonight some fried
clams with a homemade tart sauce it
switch clams Chef Ramsey he's one of the
best chefs in the world you know
standing right next to me and was uh
very surreal
generously season them with the flour
straight in Into the Fire and then again
a nice little season there okay
yeah the minute the customer rides at
the table they sit down and we need to
give them fresh hand cut homemade potato
chips a warm welcome M no those are good
this place is more laidback so I think
the chips are a good idea it's different
nice hi good evening do have res
[Music]
I thought it was great that Chef Ramsay
could show us how to make such a simple
thing like potato chips that everybody
would
love we do have a special appetizer
today deep fried clams with a homemade T
sauce all right we'll get that yeah do
potato chips going well specials going
well keep it going yeah nice atmosphere
in the dying really good clams there we
are clams every day love the clams they
said that's the best thing that they've
ever had here so it's going really good
we're not serving dirty bowls to the
table let's go
[Music]
MIA I didn't think he was going to come
back I was really really surprised that
he came back so quickly I am angry about
things that transpired earlier in the
day
still
[Music]
hours after threatening to sell the
business owner Billy returns to The
Handlebar just in time for dinner
service there was absolutely no part of
me that still wanted Chef Ramsey to be
here I wanted him to be gone Billy come
on let go of it when Billy came back he
had his bad attitude of yeah whatever
Billy please I love you that's why I'm
here that's all that matters that's all
that matters I can honestly say that I
love my wife more than anything in this
world so I came back here for my wife
while Billy tries to reconnect with his
restaurant I need my food Melissa
struggles to give the weight staff
complete orders I ran half the [__]
order I need the rest of it there's a
lot of problems who's this for here
Melissa it's been here in 37 minutes I
don't know the creeps I forgot half of
it
so Melissa just stopped communicating I
mean that's just how Melissa is and I
think that's when we ran into problems
are any of my Foods coming out for any
of my tables I have no
idea take I'm so freaking we've been
waiting communication is the one thing
and it's not happening right now oh boy
and I was you know in the weed so much I
really couldn't tell who was waiting and
was wanting I need salmon pontier
there's the salmon on that I think
melista got very flustered back back
there this place was total chaos it's
9:00 I've been here since what time 5:30
I just don't know what to say with the
orders backed up in the kitchen killing
me killing me whatever God help us
impatient hungry customers begin taking
out their frustrations you should have
come on each other know what you're
talking about before you open up your
mouth I can open up my mouth I need time
you do have you please stop talking to
my parents this way that's ridiculous
it's a total disaster and uh really
think I'm to the point now that I don't
know what else to do come on Billy can
we talk about it yeah Billy has no
choice but to listen to Chef Ramsey
because if he won't listen then we might
as well just shut the doors and walk
away right now I have never ever ever
seen my kitchen fall apart like that
ever ever on our busiest nights never
have I seen that ever Melissa has to
talk now this is the most crucial stage
of the service where she has to open up
and and talk and get help from the other
get help it's just delegate with so many
tables on the man is one of the top
chefs in the world and um maybe I should
um put aside the ill feelings and listen
to what he has to say Melissa may not be
communicating but the menu is
vaster
yeah I see what you're saying at that
point I was very open-minded to his
ideas seriously I'm pleased you're back
yeah I you're the you're the foundation
of this place we have a little chat with
the staff because I think they would
like to hear that we're all on the same
track the first hour of service was
amazing and then we got backed up we got
backed up bad Melissa you refused to
communicate I didn't know what the [__]
was going on yeah I agree with you
honestly this menu has to come down yes
that has to be condensed it' be
appreciated new small Dynamic menu a
menu that we can push out it'll be real
nice to get a new menu that'll be more
concise in order it'll be good relaunch
tomorrow night we have to make it the
success get some sleep
yes in preparation for the
relaunch Gordon's team worked through
the night updating handlebar tired dated
[Music]
look ready let's have a look at the new
handle bar let's go we
go oh wow oh
wow oh my God it's gorgeous this place
looks awesome it's fresh it's new Billy
it's warm there's nothing that's
Antiquated oh my
god
wow it's awesome feeling wow wow is all
I can say wow wow wow yeah wow what
about the lamps no more gloves no more
gloves no more gloves we are no longer
stuck in the 80s look at it warm bright
vibrant happy
yes thank you thank you everything is
awesome it's incredible I'm totally
Blown Away Billy you have Long Island's
first ever
Gastropub Gastropub what the [__] is a
gastropub what's a gastro pub good
question gastro pub Good Question Answer
I've never heard of a gastro pub though
if we're the First on Long Island that
is so incredibly awesome now Gast Pub is
warm open All Hours come and relax and
enjoy with no intimidation we cater for
everybody it's perfect for the
neighborhood there are 25 gastro pubs in
Manhattan and they are doing a
phenomenal amount of business a pub with
an emphasis on Fine Food at reasonable
prices that kind of hit home was exactly
the type of place that my wife and
myself will look at to turn it
[Music]
into knowing Billy and Carolyn's love
for motorcycle riding let's go ready to
Make Some Noise yes Gordon has organized
handlebar first annual motorcycle rally
to help spread the word about the
relaunch athetic atic but what Billy and
Carolyn don't know is Gordon has reached
out to another like
Enthusiast and rock and roll legend
twisty sister's very own D Snider hey
good to see thank you so much for coming
car
[Music]
are I never would have imagined here I
would get on my bike and ride with Chef
Ramsey and D Snider I was like oh my God
how cool is that really are you ready
yes we are it was phenomenal that Gordon
Ramsey got him to come here and help us
kick off the new start of the
[Music]
restaurant it was nice to get out there
and ride it was nice to see that jef
Ramsey could ride a motorcycle and enjoy
himself it was a lot of fun all right
let's go get these out the grand
reopening of handlebar tonight come down
to The Handlebar is reopening tonight
grand reopening come on down come on
down I'm smiling because I feel that The
Handlebar is pointed in the right
direction now we have some place to go
and some place to look forward
[Music]
to now that the word had spread Gordon
gets back to the crucial task of
introducing the new Gastro Pub menu
That's the menu in front of it look at
it there is nothing complicated on there
whether it's the steak muscles the
salmon the sausage everything is so
simply done the new menu I think is uh
phenomenal he Consolidated it down to a
lot of the comfort food type favorites
just served in a different light Melissa
this is the night that we make the
statement and when we start getting in
the wheat you have to come out yourself
and open up yes sir Chef Ramsey put his
effort into this to change us so we
going to try not to let him down we're
going to start confirming the first ever
gastr Pub in Long Island after the bomb
last night I'm sweating I'm nervous to
see how my kitchen pulls it together
make it
[Music]
work coming up it's relaunch night
welcome welcome welcome and there's a
lot of questions still to be answered
will Melissa be able to handle the
pressure the salmon looks black
underneath I'm going to hang myself will
Billy lose hope this isn't cook fall
apart and will The Handlebar finally
have a successful evening I'm sorry but
I'm not serving [__] like that or will
it go up in Flames that's it find out
next on Kitchen
Nightmares good evening welcome thank
you it's the grand reopening of The
Handlebar nice to see my D welcome
welcome welcome and Chef Ramsay's
motorcycle rally has clearly spread the
word about the relaunch enjoy your meal
thank you let's go let's go let's go
with Billy appearing to embrace Chef
Ram's changes everything's homemade
everything all eyes are now on Melissa
to step it up in the kitchen all right
stay focused here we go everybody is
excited to come in and see how it looks
now and see what's going on with the
menu and everything else can I have the
Portell Mushroom Melt grilled chicken
sandwich salmon good you all will be
pleased with the food tonight thank
you Melissa I need the shrimp cocktail
and then the salads and then the
Entre all
right
Melissa Melissa listen to me I want this
communication ramped up tonight you need
to connect the minute you stop talking
we're
[__] I think Melissa needs to be more
assertive and keep everybody under
control let's go too quiet for
me as the restaurant fills up thank you
and customers embrace the new gastr pup
venue perfect this is good Gordon takes
a moment to make a special announcement
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome a
local Legend twisty sisters yes D Snider
woohoo D give up
hey
hey D came in through the door on that
bike it was just amazing everybody was
clapping and cheering and having a great
time how cool is this huh all right
here's the deal in honor of the grand
reopening of handlebar restaurant we're
going to be auctioning this bike off so
if you want to bid on this beautiful
holy David
Sportster you can go to handlebar
restaurant website and put a bid in
there and all the proceeds will go to
the March
dimes ladies and gentlemen D
Snider with d Snider's family and
friends now seated I'm going for porell
Mushroom Melt in the first fully packed
house in over a year State F chips house
house Salen sure thank you the kitchen
is about to be
tested the salmon looks black under
[Music]
Melissa I don't think it's burnt
honestly pass me the spatula I think
it's
okay no way Madam yeah I got you B I'm
not serving charcoal [__] like that no
[__] disgusting Melissa thought she
could just take care of everything
herself and she had two other cooks and
didn't ask for their help it's a recook
I'm very sorry Beth I hope it is better
me who
Missy I'm so
sorry in her rush to fill orders
freaking salmon Melissa starts
sacrificing the quality of the food this
isn't cook [__] look at the middle of
that [__]
salmon
gross that Sal looked like what you'd
find in a seafood section like it was
shiny and it little cold like you
[__] kidding me the salmon we sent
came back [__] raw so we're doing it
again for the third time freaking salmon
let's do this I think Melissa got very
flustered back there falling apart why
are we falling apart do we have any
other salmon elsewhere she where is my
salmon find the freaking salmon Billy if
it burnt or it's raw again I'm going to
shove it down somebody's throat
everything just kept compounding and
compounding to the point where it was a
total
disaster you got to be kidding me I'm
going to hang
myself i' burnt the [__] out of this
after first overcooking no [__] why
then undercooking the salmon Melissa
hopes the third time is the
charm she's got to open up and [__]
communicate if she doesn't start
communicating now we're [__] yeah
please yeah she needs to utilize the
other two cooks that she has in the
kitchen it's not a oneman show and it
can never work if she thinks it can be
honey let's just get it right time
Melissa use these two guys I'm I want to
hear it open up communicate yeah you
know what you want to cook that I know
please thank you I will take care of the
vegge good girl I realize I can't take
care of the line on my own Salt and
Pepper please I really need to open up
and communicate and get things going
your salmon is coming honey I'm very
sorry lovely good to go thank you very
much honey
Gordon's persistence with Melissa
appears to finally be paying off you
give it a thumbs up all right there we
go all right we got to get this together
I need three YB fries three fries right
now at the moment I understand Chef
Ramsey's whole concept is to communicate
and keep everything in order I got to
get it going as long as I can
communicate with the guys next to me it
will get it working properly I need to
concentrate on D's table yes we are
doing it now take the two burgers
whenever you can Melissa really shocked
me tonight where she was able to ask
Eric and George oh can you do this can
you get this we are doing real well to
keep it up very very good amazing lovely
let go tonight we had a couple of really
large screw-ups but in the end it all
worked out a great menu right everybody
was happy I feel very excited I feel
good that's
[Music]
it in the next couple of days the word
continued to spread throughout Long
Island about its first guest asro pup we
have a Wonder a full new menu that was
the best work I've ever eaten I thought
it was cook really well reinvigorated by
the New Direction and updated menu
Melissa has found her passion again one
small Caesar one small house Chef Ramsey
being here has definitely brought new
life into my job chicken sandwiches up
and Out Burgers up and out I do have
more passion about it I want to make
sure everything is good I'm surprised on
myself now even the weight staff has
taken it upon themselves to maintain the
cleanliness of the restaurant we're
going to make a list of what needs to be
cleaned every night cuz we want to keep
it clean and we want to make it look
like
presentable and Billy with renewed hope
and determination is moving forward
something to enjoy while they're waiting
to take your order inspiring everyone to
make the handlebar a
success well done this place is going to
be a success I tell you great location
great food great gastro pub my wife and
myself are very appreciative of what he
did did seemed like there was a black
cloud hanging over the
handlebar um I think the sun's starting
to shine a little bit congratulations
I'm being Long Island's first gastro
PR okay good
night Chef ramsy came to my restaurant
went above and beyond anything I could
have possibly asked for and I know this
restaurant's going to be successful from
here on out
[Music]
that was tough very tough indeed we made
a lot of changes changed the menu change
the decor but there's one thing in there
that I thought was completely
unchangeable and that was Bill and we
even managed
[Music]
that